hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play to neveress Lake okay we
actually are right back where we started
before we got our wet oil now okay all
right we're fine we're fine Stan being
noises nothing to be worried about I
think I can use it now maybe I can Kurt
alright so that should have shut off the
water flowing out of the pipe
Jeremy which means that we can go back
I'm like really hesitant now because I
don't know what to expect and that's
like the best part in a scary game when
you've done it let me let me hit that
save just in case
shut up shut up man I don't know why but
it feels a lot more atmospheric right
now than it has
Derk oh boy
you're not gonna get me no give me I'm
gonna beat you by charging in tough
can't charge in here oh boy keep movin
move faster boy tell us by mistake
rise big mistake
Oh
no good dad no good not good
that depth or was that just knocked me
out because you do that a lot in this
game
all right keep going
okay all right we're good not good a
barely conscious
but I'm so Raz
man look at that camera shake widescreen
2:35 good some camera shake up in here
more camera shock everything gone if any
of you know what I'm talking about it's
an awesome video by Freddie Wong you
should check it out
it's a Freddie Wong with that big meal
time oh boy oh boy oh boy oh this looks
fun oh I found it yeah I don't know if
it was that much of a puzzle but I found
it I'm the greatest ever
anyway I'll tell you about Freddie Wong
and epic meal times collab video oh it
was in most amazing thing I've ever seen
in my life widescreen 2 3 5 well it
wouldn't be a Freddie Wong video without
some guns and my right haters ok so
there's some sort of rope here
that's an old note the door is broken I
don't think that it can be open I can
open it by myself
maybe that heavy stone can help me okay
alright then
this heavy stone right here I can't
touch anymore sorry I touched your soup
don't touch this don't I know I know
what the deal is I know what the deal is
I gotta push it in there cuz there's a
guy screw you then will you then
I can't go in here you kidding me
really whatever whatever here we go
don't know why don't know why this is a
good decision what I'm doing it
Hey look a Sadie save Hey look a
tinderbox and bow art did you save don't
jump out at me do we got plenty of oil
but I haven't gotten any in a while
surprisingly I mean they've been like
force feeding the oil for the past it
was for the best few parts here I wonder
how long this thing is too because like
this is one of I mean it's not custom
store it's like a total conversion mod
so it could be like up to 20 parts you
look in terms of mods like cry fear was
a 30 plus part series but that was on a
whole nother level I suppose
it's like stupid quiet I couldn't get
that why can't I move that rock I think
that rock was to something else and this
is like moving from over it now box what
happens if I throw the box in the pit
you fall down whoa that's like total
graphical error pit that's like hey well
no yeah said oil there's the oil and
ahem ah bah oh maybe I need to use a
hammer to like hammer out some stuff for
the thingy the rock it had rocks around
it so yo Dawg heard you like rocks ah oh
oh go faster [ __ ] you know man Oh
god damn it god damn it god damn it damn
you damn you to hell
wooo-oooo run at all my little look at
him oh you know so tough
oh you just ugly ah not that way this
way hit the save oh save on the run
man he's catching up
[ __ ] I know I couldn't get out that
place so I'm not gonna go that way
it's that way I can't go that is not the
way okay
alright we're fine God shut up shut up I
see it glow I I saw it glow well there
it is I screw you rock then I'm gonna
just hammer this door cannot use this
item this way cannot use this item this
way oh oh no I done bad I done bad
I don't bad I don't bad ah I've done bad
oh boy I've really done bad I [ __ ] up
I [ __ ] up I [ __ ] ah well damn I done
goofed
alright okay then good thing I hit that
save on the way gah gah drop me right
here my love with a monster
come at me bro I'm ready for you
come at me bro what's up you ain't got
nothing
yeah I got nothing on me yeah oh I've ly
Oh what happened your legs oh it's so
sad okay I saw some way I can't move
these rocks by hand really is this is
this is this the deal what's going on
do I miss something else okay what's
down here ah-ha okay there's plenty of
stuff around here maybe they got a hint
good find a chisel chisel would make
sense wouldn't it well I'm gonna get
lost in here okay
what was that I thought I heard
something okay whatever don't matter and
did it so don't go down this way if I'm
being chased by a monster don't go that
way
and don't go that way just follow the
lights follow the lights
I found the lights after I played that
custom story nothing in there check it
up there anyplace to do leap park or
ledge I don't know I don't see anything
ah oh oh in a minute
hello the chipper is stuck in the stone
the stone seems fused in to its place oh
that's why I'm talking about the rock
okay all right it didn't give me a note
sound so how about we hammer boom there
we go give me that and monster
come out come out wherever you are
no [ __ ] he's got an axe hate
gotta [ __ ] you
I'm gonna make sure he goes this way hey
what's up huh but bro all right yeah
yeah yeah does he have an axe nope no no
wait how the [ __ ] do I lose them oh yeah
here get out of here get out of here
here bro
no one likes you so ugly Chris smells
bad
what baby the combination doesn't work
Hey what the hell
[Music]
you just go away get an axe okay
whatever I there's another pathway down
here maybe I need a third thing oh oh oh
oh I always I always do that I always go
I always go check swear one of our
monster disappears I always go check and
that's like stupid oh wait where the
chisel go oh okay up you stupid all you
mother oh you son of a [ __ ]
I swear what is wrong with you what is
wrong with you there okay hey yeah I did
it okay there we go
I did it sorry that camera been off the
entire time probably is it off now I
can't even tell I don't see the camera
okay yeah who's there I yeah it is why
are you are you my wife yeah yes No
hurry you must get us out of here kids
are on the other side I'm gonna go find
some I tried to do a better job the
voice-acting lady I shouldn't be so
critical all right okay oh yeah I like
that
hey baby I'm gonna get you I'm coming
okay yeah no time pick up chicks at the
club no sneak up on your melody I'm
coming to get you from across no but
just like you go get you hey did they
come running
or they go running either way they're
running so yeah okay nothing error I
need to save took dr. T junk kids come
on oh wait till I find an axe all right
so there's there was a door an actual
pathway door back there but I didn't
want to leave the area for flooring
because apparently there's a lot of
stuff that you could explore and never
hit like I got distracted by that
monster I didn't go down that hallway
there might have been something there
who knows I guess I won't know this
looks like a long suspiciously long
hallway
viciously long suspiciously long as if
I'm supposed to be chased by something
probably gonna be chased by something
just saying hello clothes boink
pink nope uh-huh nothing in here what's
the point
alright anyway that's all the time I got
for this part thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye bye